[Music]
gentian impact is a massive game that on
its initial launch was truly magical
but i think i won't be alone here to say
that most people had a honeymoon phase
and the end game became the crossroads
for many players that's why when i got
to adventure rank 35
shortly after the release of the game i
completely fell off
with no new events at that time and
before the arrival of any new characters
that end game grind was brutal back then
and didn't have enough of a draw for me
to stay and complete even my dailies
but six months later picking up gentian
impact again turned out to be an
interesting experience because of its
unique combination of traits this game
has
so if like me you're considering playing
again then this might be the video for
you
if you'd like to see more genjin impact
content let us know by liking this video
so we can do more in the future
after not playing for six months i
started up genji impact again
and i initially felt indifferent to the
game at this point there have been a few
amount of updates added including a new
mounted area to explore and new primo
gem goals to hit as i continue playing
my feeling of fomo
or fear of missing out slowly started to
grow more and more which i guess comes
with the territory of any live service
game that you haven't played in a while
seeing everyone with their pet sealies
fully decked out team comps at level 90
and completed spiral abyss made me feel
a little more insecure about my current
setup
but having that goal in the back of my
mind after being away for so long
gave me some incentive to stick around
and put more hours back into the game
yes i'm still getting burnout from
farming the same places over and over
again
but this open world with all of its
beautiful vistas to this day is still
complete eye candy and hasn't lost its
charm
even pushing its limits can be kind of
fun specifically using wind elemental
resonance
a special five-star catalyst and mona
sprint her ground speed nears 200
and is so fast that the game can't even
keep loading up assets ahead of her
small things like this that people can
find depending on which characters they
have makes finding different
combinations and abilities a fun
experience
part of the appeal of this game is
obviously the characters and their
unique designs
and i think every anime fan can agree
that developer mihoyo designed some
really amazing characters
with the release of new and interesting
characters coming up fairly frequently
i'm confident that mihoyo won't have any
problems in the future coming up with
amazing ideas and characters
everyone is going to have different
experiences on how the game keeps them
engaged but for me specifically getting
tartaglia aka
child after having no main dps for my
entire time is a small push that made me
want to invest more time into it
finally coming up with the creative team
synergy that worked together well after
different combinations
turned out to be satisfying when i
figured it out because people are at
different levels and have different sets
of characters depending on how much time
and money they've invested i feel like
this tailor-made investment for me was
engaging and invited me to spend more
time with genjin
this does bring up a good point though
is gotcha still a bad mechanic
while it can turn out to be harmful in
under certain circumstances i think
genji's impact incorporated well enough
into the system of a pretty much tripoli
experience
that i feel like it's hard to judge it
from my perspective and rather it should
be judged by each person individually
what i will say is that having some
experience in the gotcha fields with
older games such as brave frontier and
final fantasy brave exodus when i return
to those games months later like i did
with genjin
i wasn't nearly as interested even
though i put a lot of time into those
games
they lasted about an hour on my phone
before i deleted them again which
definitely says something genji impact
stands out in that regard
and i enjoy enough to spend time with it
again and i'll be patiently waiting to
see the new map section that opens up
with the traveler's new element
and obviously the game's community
speaks for itself as well as it's one of
the biggest live service games still
standing next to other behemoths such as
fortnite apex legends and others
i think it's safe to say that i've got
my eye back on gadget impact
[Music]
you